hanson happy Valentine's Day to you all
you're welcome very excited viewers at
home that you are here with us as a
happy Valentine's Sailor Zak and Isaac
and you're at Bridgewater Hall in
Manchester a night before last at Rock
City in Nottingham tonight and what can
the crowds expect well I mean it's a
completely different show you see the
video I mean with a fork astre I mean
we've gotten to play with some
incredible symphonies in the u.s.
already and now we're you know sharing
this with one thing about this is it's
it's almost like going to an ultimate
listening party we encourage people to
sort of actually sit and just take it in
because you haven't just this full
orchestra wrapped around a rock band and
there's songs you know I mean there are
songs you know like when bops in the
show where's the love and then and but
it's really story I mean it's sort of
taking people on this musical ride and a
lot of people like we've seen orchestras
afterwards be like hey thank you so much
for doing this with us because they see
people coming to see symphony shows that
aren't typically seeing symphony shows
and obviously we're excited to see some
of that world come to check out our show
in a different way sort of it meets in
the middle you know I mean we obviously
all know from the fact that you know
when you are barely out of short shows
us you're all incredibly talented
measure for this for this I mean you
were clearly involved in the end
arrangements of the classics and new
music right yeah well we all and we all
started off playing classical pianist
and knowing how to read music but
knowing how to score the whole symphony
is a totally different thing so we we
worked with a great arranger named Dave
Campbell who's won Oscars and he'd
worked on our records in the past and so
it was a great way to just bring
somebody in you were comfortable with it
could really take all our ideas and then
go and we're like this is what we want
it sound like he's like oh you meant
like this is to push yourself I mean if
you're excited about something you can
be excited to share it and yeah and so
you're asking your fans to come with you
and have stories to tell and so the idea
of setting this bar of like hey what's
what if we did this with an orchestra
and it allows us to take the show to the
places we've never been before doing
about the story in a lot of ways the
story of the show is really the story of
us it's sort of Allah you can say if a
greatest hits is what you've done
the story of string theory is really why
we've done it and and so as people
listen to the lyrics and they hear these
songs
really talking about sort of your
manifesto I'm a quarter of a century in
the music business I mean this is how
you started maybe you burst you wanted
to see what yeah you can still fit in
today that's a good going Bob is
possibly one of the catchiest Tunes ever
written and it is a song that everyone
remembers you only have to mention it
and everyone starts singing right so
from that point on how is your musical
journey grown because people always talk
back to that song in a good way we're so
proud of that song because I mean it's a
song that we wrote when I was 8 right
and and to be able to still sing it and
what it talks about it talks about the
passage of time that most things in life
won't last for many different things
with it as well and so I mean that we
wouldn't have included it in the show if
the story and the message that's in that
wasn't McPhee to who we are as people
and so the other thing you think I mean
what he says it was a song we wrote and
so the fact that we started off as young
as we did it was always our music yeah I
think that's part of what's allowed us
to move forward and I mean the
songwriting the the love of
craftsmanship is really what's always
driven us to do we yeah the scary thing
is actually that was five years into our
band playing that's the scary part
Helen Arthur you guys still talking to
each other I mean not just 25 years in a
band 25 years in a band with your
brothers I spent five minutes in a room
with mine each other.if dissidents I
don't know I will say interestingly I
think interview is getting to talk about
your process can you talk about like you
is kind of therapeutic to sit next to
each other and talk about each other
things right now I will also say though
that there is a little bit of when the
workday is over there is a tendency to
scatter a bit because you do spend so
much time together that there is there
is definitely a need for separation and
and that's healthy I mean you know it's
a little bit like when you're married
for you know as my wife and I've been in
for a dozen years you still got to go on
dates and you got to remember to do that
similarly in a band with brothers you
actually got to do the opposite really
I've been around you're a little too
much it's time for saying
called what are we fighting for and it's
not theoretical I mean it's about us and
so that's something you deal with but
but we love what we do so you you keep
finding the way through it which is good
because the valentine's day as i
mentioned before you're playing rock
city in nottingham tonight any
Valentine's Day treats for the fans
maybe a few extra love songs just for
you no you know which will play some
music and hopefully they'll bring their
dates and we'll make it a great night
and I know your families are back in in
the US and I'll break you a bit of
confidence here during the ad break they
did say the time difference is helping
because they forgot it was Valentine's
Day love Lisi Hansen oh good luck with
the rest of your tour and thank you for
coming in to see us so there you go
Hansen out on tour up and down the UK
right now